bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france des mesures qui
impliquerait donc davantage les
localités ce que c'est un revirement de
la part du premier ministre
on peut parler de revirements moi je
parle surtout de sparadrap dans la
mesure où la politique sanitaire de
johnson a été pour l'instant je marque
et sous le sceau de l'échec
c'est une politique qui n'a pas du tout
porté ses fruits alors maintenant il
faut faire une correction de tir je
crois que c'est le meilleur des thermes
et cette correction de tir passe par une
plus grande décentralisation ou
documents des concentrations mais
l'important c'est de voir que bolton sol
comme beaucoup de personnes qui plus ou
moins est lié à ce qui est logique
économiste et libéral s'est trompé
c'était le cas de troy 7,4 bolton euros
tous ces gens là il ya même si les
théories qui tient réussir je connais
quelques-uns qui il ya quelques mois
encore on lui disait l'immunité
collective c'est le meilleur c'est la
meilleure des solutions
cette immunité collective a échoué et
donc c'est quand même une séance de
rattrapage que le temps que brendan
morrison qui a contracté le coffee 19 il
ya quelques mois est ce que ça a eu
malgré tout il y aura un quelconque
impact sur sa gestion
dans la foulée de la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui vous dirais que le royaume
uni n'a finalement pas tiré les leçons
de la première vague alors et c'est sûr
et certain que la maladie de boris
johnson a une grande influence sur sa
propre façon de penser parce que lorsque
vous êtes malade et vous allez remarquer
que vous êtes malade un peu par votre au
foot quand même la raison doit
l'emporter
je ne dirais pas qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une phase complètement
différente ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est le chant quand pu être retirés ont
conduit boris johnson maintenant à
retirer les vis alors en attendant de
nouvelles mesures plus fermes
elle devrait être annoncée ces
prochaines heures est ce qu'elles seront
acceptés en irlande en écosse par
exemple alors ça c'est une question
mental il y a pas seulement le preneur
coronavirus qui hantent les travées de
la chambre de décoloniser l'ordre il y a
aussi le problème du bruit si tu es là
il ya deux problèmes qui sont peut-être
pas liés l'un par rapport à l'autre mais
qui sont devenus liés par rapport à
l'autre qui sont au centre la politique
britannique
et on ne sait pas du tout comment vont
aboutir les négociations et pignans
européenne mais ce qui se passe
phénomène assez intéressant c'est que
lui allant du nord n'est pas du tout
prêt prête à céder aux lubies de ben
johnson est aussi tel est le cas de
l'ecosse jamais qui a eu un référendum
il ya quatre ans sur la dépendance de
l'ecosse il a échoué ce référendum
mais aujourd'hui les nationalistes et
que c'est madame car je n'en en tête
reprennent du poil de la bête et si
véritablement la situation dans le
royaume uni devait se dégrader à la fois
à cause de la commune mais aussi et
surtout à cause du bruit de sites
là il ya des conséquences à moyen long
terme qui sont véritablement très
problématique pour molsheim qui pose
même la question de l'unité du royaume
uni
je ne pense pas que pour l'instant le
soyons dans une phase où la dgos a
accédé à son indépendance
mais c'est fort possible qu'il y ait un
processus qui s'enclenche qui avouent
qu'ils un jour assure you tu es alors on
l'a vu ce week-end dans des élus du nord
de l'angleterre qui ont exprimé leur
colère samedi face à ceux ses possibles
nouvelles restrictions sanitaires des
élus qui redoutent comme ailleurs en
europe la fermeture des pubs et des
cafés il juge les mesures de soutien à
l'emploi suffisante est ce qu'ils auront
et ce qu'ils auraient les moyens de
s'opposer à ces nouvelles restrictions
je ne pense pas qu'ils auront les moyens
parce que vous si vous prenez de tel
moment donné il ya un effet boomerang
qui risque de jouer mais le plus
important c'est véritablement et c'est
pourquoi j'insiste là dessus c'est un
affrontement entre le pouvoir central de
londres et des pouvoirs décentralisés
vous savez j'ai écouté avec intérêt la
ce que disait votre chroniqueur sion
économique s'illustre et ils disaient
oui on rappeler notre envie de plus
grandes fédéralisation et bien moi je
parle pas de risque pour havret même de
chance partout en europe on remarque
qu'il y a une volonté alors on peut le
critiquer sur certains aspects comme les
personnes soient plus impliqués sur les
lieux mêmes des décisions à prendre et
certainement la prise en compte de cars
régionaux ou le cas locaux fait partie
aujourd'hui l'une des leçons à tirer de
la crise du coc vide
c'est ce qui est en train de faire
mourir jeune ce n'est ce pas trop tard
une question alors revoir la situation
sanitaire en tout dernière lettre
instant est ce que par les infections au
courant d'un virus augmente dans toute
l'angleterre mais il ya des villes du
nord comme liverpool 1-1 manchester ou
encore newcastle et qui connaissent une
augmentation disproportionnée d'autres
zones rurales de l'est de l'angleterre
ont à l'envers ce moins de 20 cas pour
100000 habitants comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on explique cette
situation
moi je pense à phénomène général en tout
cas les régions urbaines sont beaucoup
plus touchés parce que là la circulation
dans tout le sens dans tous les sens du
terme est beaucoup plus dense
ça ne veut pas dire que les régions
rurales ne seront pas je pense qu'il
faut faire preuve d'énormes humilité dès
qu'on parle de cette maladie ce qu'on
disait il ya six mois s'est avéré faux
plus de bois juste je dirais que
curieusement la grande bretagne après
avoir fait moins d'erreurs s'européanise
à l'heure où elle veut quitter l'europe
c'est à dire que ce qu'elle est en train
de vivre mais de façon pas plus grave
que certains pays et malheureusement des
chiffres en france ne sont pas bons non
plus un peu comparable
c'est que aujourd'hui la grande bretagne
qui voulait un peu donné des leçons par
la voix de vos rues de mission nous
reste de l'europe est en train est de
devoir de recevoir des leçons parce que
elle a failli au moins un an durant les
premiers mois et ce qui se passe dans
les grandes
le passé aussi par ailleurs donc nous
grandes villes européennes on le voit
parler donc pas parié dans notre
métropole française
merci beaucoup gilbert casasus je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur en
études européennes